50 ans divine organisé vendredi dernier
son premier Grand Prix de karting
c'était au circuit Jean-Pierre Beltoise
de trappe 50 entreprises école et
start-up du territoire ont participé à
ce rendez-vous les gagnants la section
karting du Crédit Agricole sport l'un
des membres justement de cette section
Cartier est avec nous je le disais en
début d'émission c'est Fabrice canard et
parmi les participants aussi il y avait
une team TV 78 vous en faisiez partie
Mathilde mais aussi Nicolas dandry
bonsoir la rédaction TV 78 on va revenir
sur ce trophée on vous étiez aussi dans
l'équipe on pose à trio exactement comme
toutes les équipes d'ailleurs qui
participaient à ce grand prix pour nous
comme pour notre invité d'ailleurs il y
a eu une journée qui a commencé par
trois ateliers de formation à la
conduite nous avons commencé avec un
exercice sur l'éco-conduite c'est-à-dire
sur la manière d'économiser de l'essence
en conduisant sur une partie du circuit
il fallait rouler en moyenne à 40 km/h
et Stéphane gressin nous donne justement
quelques astuces s'écouter le principal
ce serait quoi regardez loin bien
anticiper les événements d'accélérer le
moins souvent possible tout en
maintenant une un dynamisme et une
inertie qui nous permettra de rouler
sans gêner bien entendu alors participé
à cet exercice je sais pas comment ça
s'est passé pour vous alors très bien
fait partie des découvertes et c'était
c'était vraiment intéressant de
d'économiser du carburant c'est
important pour tous et vraiment c'était
c'était
bien enrichissant je suis assez fier
parce que j'ai fait quand même une
moyenne de 42 km/h et j'ai réussi à
faire en fait 5,7 litres pour 100 km
l'un des meilleurs scores de la journée
je crois l'un des meilleurs Bracieux
donc je suis assez fier là-dessus
deuxième exercice de conduite c'est le
freinage d'urgence et là je vous propose
de regarder cet extrait c'est avec vous
mais Mathilde regardez là on se lance 80
km heure la vitesse est marquée au
niveau du tableau de bord et en fait je
vais devoir freiner lorsque
je j'apercevrai le mannequin qui est
derrière le SAMU d'ailleurs vous me
direz à quel moment vous le voyez si
vous voulez
d'accord donc 80 il est derrière SAMU
voilà
vous avez pas vu le mannequin
il va pas être content
et oui ça peut arriver sur la route donc
ça veut dire là à 80 je peux pas
m'arrêter ça veut dire que vous l'avez
il était où le mannequin a-t-il il était
très bien caché le mannequin Nicolas
consistait cet exercice parce qu'il y
avait pas uniquement le fait de
d'observer de découvrir qu'il y avait un
mannequin derrière le véhicule il
fallait tester les freins du véhicule et
du coup se rendre compte de l'entière
capacité de freinage de son véhicule et
c'était un exercice très intéressant
parce que même moi j'avais pas la
connaissance qu'on pouvait freiner aussi
fort et aussi rapidement et il y avait
un second exercice c'était freiné sur un
terrain mouillé et du coup ne pas
écraser un plot ce que j'ai plutôt bien
réussi mais c'était aussi un exercice un
fort en adrénaline Grégory mais c'est
vrai quand on est sorti de la voiture on
était un peu voilà je pense que c'est le
terme qu'on est sorti là c'est le pic
d'adrénaline avec avec ce freinage
d'urgence effectivement avec ces deux
scénarios il y avait le mannequin qui
arrive au dernier moment finalement
c'était le temps de réaction qu'on
testait plus et là après le freinage sur
route mouillé c'est vrai que moi je
croyais on sortait vider un peu de cet
atelier je sais pas ce que vous en avez
pensé Fabrice canard oui oui c'est vrai
on vit pas ces moments là tous les jours
et heureusement d'ailleurs et c'est
c'est curieux de de pouvoir frein aussi
fort y compris sur le mouillé avec avec
la direction du véhicule qui prend tout
de suite alors on pensait qu'on allait
déraper et finalement non pas du tout
vraiment c'était bien alors dernier
atelier justement vous en parliez
Grégory et en plus c'est vous qui avez
fait cet exercice le temps de réaction
tester le temps de réaction via un
simulateur de conduite avec différents
scénarios et bien oui effectivement il y
avait différents scénarios avec
peut-être des surprises qui apparaissent
sur la route des des véhicules qui
grillent la priorité et là faut savoir
réagir de la bonne manière et c'est vous
Grégory qui avait fait cet atelier
d'ailleurs nous avons demandé au
formateur Franck brégion de faire un
bilan sur votre attitude Grégory a été
bon parce que effectivement je pense que
bah comme tout à chacun quand on se met
dans le simulateur on essaie de faire
bien en fait donc donc d'avoir une
attitude
la mieux possible alors même si c'est
pas même s'il n'a pas été parfait dans
le cas de Grégory au moins il met des
choses en place et même si c'est pas
parfait le fait de mettre des choses en
place bah ça améliore les choses et
c'est ce qu'on veut même si bon voilà
pour son ego alors peut-être voulu
complètement s'arrêter avant la voiture
mais au moins ça tape pas fort et c'est
ce qu'on veut ce qu'on veut c'est pas
joué sa vie sur la route c'est voilà
c'est tant pis ça tape mais ça t'a pas
fort mon idée c'est de de tendre vers ça
mais au moins le peu de choses qu'on met
en place au moins s'améliorera chose et
c'est ça qu'on veut absolument bravo
bravo Grégory merci mais après oui c'est
vrai que c'était pas évident le fait
d'être sur un simulateur ça peut laisser
un petit peu pantois au début le fait
aussi qu'on soit observé d'ailleurs on a
l'impression de repasser son permis mais
après comme le disait très bien le
formateur il s'agit de sécurité routière
de scénario qui peuvent se présenter où
il faut mettre en place des choses pour
éviter justement les draps le pire c'est
ça
et alors l'après-midi Grégory et bien
c'était consacré à la course de karting
d'abord avec une phase de qualification
pour déterminer le placement sur la
grille et un départ donné façon 24
Heures du Mans entre 1925 et 1969 vous
le voyez les véhicules sont garés et
bien en épi les pilotes sont en face
j'ai pris le départ pour l'Équipe TV 78
très très belle course j'ai accéléré de
toutes mes forces et puis en fait il
faut prendre le kart et puis partir
ensuite et après je vous laisse savourer
ces images regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très déçu alors mais bon c'est une belle
course on s'est bien amusé Mathilde on
s'est bien amusé non ouais franchement
c'est éclaté c'était vraiment une belle
découverte pour moi le karting
franchement c'était une première et je
me suis bien amusée
je pense qu'on est tous fatigués on va
aller se reposer je pense
effectivement on a bien dormi après
j'ai bien aimé votre regard déterminé
Grégory sur Limoges non en plus pour moi
c'était la troisième fois que je faisais
je faisais du quartier on a senti une
progression tout au long de la journée
bon le résultat 14e est dû il faut le
préciser on a fait une erreur de
stratégie on va pouvoir la débriefer
avec Fabrice canard on a fait un sixième
changement alors qu'on avait 5
changements obligatoires le sixième nous
a fait perdre du temps et en plus de ça
on l'a fait dans une limite de temps
trop rapide ce qui fait qu'au final on a
on a pris un tour de pénalité on était
de du top 10 on a fini 14e
c'est que le passage au stand devait
être fait obligatoirement dans un chrono
en fait de 30 secondes minimum et donc
nous on a fait 26 secondes sur le
dernier relais et donc et alors vous
avez vu le trophée le trophée de numéro
1 c'est notre invité qui l'a emporté
c'était quoi votre stratégie finalement
sur cette course elle est vite très vite
et toujours très vite
non non mais pas par rapport au
changement par exemple on a l'habitude
un petit peu de courir et en vérité on a
fait trois relais de 30 minutes plutôt
que plutôt que si relais d'un quart
d'heure et on a fait nos deux
changements à la suite et voilà ça nous
permet de de continuer sur sur le même
rythme toujours
le sixième changement qu'on a fait
erreur fatale ça vous fait perdre 30
secondes d'office et donc ça il faut
surtout pas faire il faut faut faire
juste les cinq les cinq arrêts
nécessaires et donc faisait 30 minutes
de course à la fin il n'était pas
fatigué il faisait pas des erreurs
mais une fois que on sort du karting
transpirant de la même façon que vous
c'est vrai 1h30 c'est ça paraît très
long enfin c'est très long pour le coup
et pour 1h30 de course pour des non
habitués à dire au karting c'est vrai
que c'était compliqué alors vous avez
donc terminé premier de la compétition
parce que c'est une compétition en
équipe on le disait il y avait trois
pilotes par par équipe même si c'est un
pilote de l'ESTACA qui a remporté la la
dernière course je crois qu'il fait les
championnats du monde d'ailleurs
finalement c'est c'est l'équipe qui a
primé c'est la stratégie c'est la
stratégie de l'équipe c'est c'est enfin
on a une équipe complémentaire assez
homogène et c'est ça qui est qui a fait
que qu'on a gagné c'est les valeurs de
l'entreprise de l'entreprise d'ailleurs
maintenant une personne toute seule peut
pas tout peut pas tout faire quoi le
niveau de la finale vous l'avez trouvé
comment ah assez élevé d'ailleurs
la personne qui a gagné la finale
justement
il nous prenait bien trois quatre
dixièmes partout on n'arrivait pas à le
suivre est-ce que c'était pas difficile
c'était notre cas de partager la piste
avec des débutants ou des on va dire pas
très expérimenté dans le monde du
quartier sur les phases de qualification
et le Grand Prix qui a duré 1h30 est-ce
que c'était pas difficile pour vous ça
demande beaucoup de concentration parce
que il faut éviter de d'aller rentrer
dans dans les personnes qui vont moins
vite et ça c'est pas toujours facile il
y a des réactions qu'on peut pas
anticiper et là c'est ça demande de
l'agilité je crois que la stratégie de
Mathilde c'était plus seulement ce
justement ce qui allait vite mais
trajectoires et essayer de les suivre et
bon ça m'a permis de gagner au moins 16
secondes sur mon premier tour qui était
vraiment pas terrible faisait une minute
16 à la fin j'étais à une minute 0 une
donc ça m'a permis quand même de
grappiller des secondes mais oui
et puis on les voyait nous dépasser
assez facilement alors il y avait
l'équipe Crédit Agricole il y avait
l'équipe Renault aussi qu'on voyait
passer sur le côté et effectivement
c'est une filiale du Crédit Agricole et
j'en fais parti alors justement vous
parlez d'entreprise est-ce que vous avez
ce jour-là créer des liens parce que
c'était le but aussi de la journée
c'était que les acteurs économiques se
rencontrent est-ce que vous avez discuté
avec d'autres entreprises peut-être des
écoles aussi d'ailleurs avaient les
ateliers du matin dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure on a discuté avec les deux
équipes d'étudiants donc ESTACA
justement qui qui avait leur pilote un
peu un peu plus
chevron avec nous et puis ISM aussi qui
finit 3e de notre de notre poule et bon
voilà on a discuté un petit peu de
l'ambiance qu'il y avait sur le circuit
mais aussi de des entreprises et de ce
qui est recherché j'ai pas réussi à le
recruter
et du coup c'est votre section la
section karting qui a remporté ce
premier Grand Prix parlez-nous de cette
section karting combien de membres la
composent est-ce que vous vous entraînez
régulièrement ce que vous participez à
d'autres trophées
alors dans la section il y a un peu plus
de 20 membres qui viennent de tous
horizons du groupe justement les
différentes filiales de Crédit Agricole
et LCL donc LCL est une filiale et donc
j'en fais partie et je
suis dans la section depuis 2005 2006 à
peu près
j'avais toujours eu envie d'en faire un
peu un peu comme vous deux trois fois
comme ça et puis ensuite voilà en
croisant les membres qui qui étaient
déjà à l'époque moi je suis j'y suis
allé là
[Musique]
un bon niveau
alors on fait des courses loisirs
d'ailleurs vous me demandiez ce qu'on
faisait c'est on fait des courses à peu
près une fois deux fois par mois et
contre d'autres entreprises
d'Île-de-France ou à l'intérieur du
Crédit Agricole il y a des courses qui
sont organisées comme ça et en termes de
palmarès justement on a gagné deux fois
de suite là contre contre les autres
sections du Crédit Agricole vous aviez
déjà arpenter le circuit Beltoise
l'imagine oui oui ça fait partie des
circuits où on vient chaque année on
doit on doit venir trois fois quatre
fois par an sur le circuit donc là pour
se préparer pas de préparation
particulière finalement c'est c'était ce
que vous faisiez c'est normal en vérité
on savait à peu près comment aller se
dérouler la course de poules mais la
course de finale on savait pas on l'a
découvert comme vous alors vous finissez
vos tours en 54 55 secondes en moyenne
c'est quoi vos conseils pour arriver à
ce temps là
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
il faut vraiment freiner comme il faut
avant le virage et ensuite commencer à
réaccélérer pendant le virage et pour
maintenir le kart et puis pouvoir
repartir on accélère pas un virage on
garde on garde le pied sur
l'accélérateur ensuite on accélère mais
on garde le moteur le moteur doit
toujours tourner un régime suffisant
pour pouvoir accélérer plus facilement
mais freiner c'est important le freinage
très très important les prochaines
étapes pour vous ce qu'il y a d'autres
déjà trophées qui sont programmés dans
votre agenda non la section organise dès
samedi prochain à Beltoise une journée
un peu familiale loisir comme ça où on
invite les amis et puis les et puis la
famille on a on a on a le barbecue sur
place aussi enfin voilà c'est c'est
quelque chose de très sympa et puis
sinon après ça sera la qualité on fait
pas pendant les vacances
parce qu'elle peut pas rejoindre votre
section que c'est internet de karting de
télé 78
non je connais pas bien les les clubs en
général les pistes comme Beltoise ou RKC
à Pontoise propose des activités club
mais sinon on les connaît pas non sur ce
trophée qui avait fut un temps un
trophée de karting de tvfils 78
peut-être que ce serait l'occasion de le
relancer pourquoi pas voilà en tout cas
c'est lancé c'est sur la table en tout
cas félicitations à vous Fabrice canard
de la section karting du Crédit Agricole
vous étiez accompagné de juste pour les
citer de Marc et locaux et de Frédéric
Dussault qui sont aussi LCL et Crédit
Agricole et ça bah bravo à eux et bravo
à vous en tout cas c'est un plaisir de
partager cette journée avec vous mais
Nicolas je sais pas pour vous Mathilde
comme expérience
du team building enfin vous le savez ça
crée des liens ça permet d'avoir
confiance les uns aux autres non c'est
une très belle expérience
le matin en plus sur les co-conduite le
freinage tout était regroupé pour passer
une bonne journée instructive sur cette
donc première journée premier trophée de
karting de 50 ans divine c'était
vendredi dernier sur le circuit Beltoise
à Trappes